there are many masterpieces built with
microscopic elegance the small and hard
to see life of the sea microbes
Marvie burrowers and they've been
photographed and catalog as part of a
massive marine collaboration of
scientists from across the globe the
census of marine life is a 10-year
program to try and uncover as much as we
can about the diversity distribution and
abundance of life in the ocean a portion
of this project the census of hard to
see marine life focused on the smallest
sea creatures and found them in
spectacular abundance there was one
sampling effort in the South Atlantic
that sample an area about the size of a
small bathroom and found 700 species of
just crustaceans most of which were were
new to science huge numbers of rarely
seen species are coming to light and
scientists are gaining a new
understanding of the dynamics of a
microbial world on which all other life
depends the microbes actually play a
very key role in the way that nutrients
move through the ocean and if they
weren't there the ocean would shut down
very quickly and the planet would shut
down very quickly census explorers
recently found that microbes form mats
on the seafloor off the west coast of
South America
these mats ranked among earth's largest
masses of life and cover a surface
comparable in size to Greece
amazingly census of marine life
estimates that all microbes in the
global ocean collectively weigh the
equivalent of 240 billion
African elephants all that the census
has learned over the last ten years
about hard to see creatures and all the
animals that live in the world's oceans
will be formally released in October
2010 the results of this massive effort
will give scientists an unprecedented
new understanding of life in the world
ocean